[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us Ukraine's
President says a mass grave has been
found in the northeastern city of issue
the city is in the kharkiv region
Ukraine's forces recaptured it from
Russia earlier this month a local police
official said 440 buddies have been
located across the region the bodies
will be exhumed for forensic examination
Mass Graves were found in izion in the
kharkiv region the necessary legal
proceedings have already been initiated
there there should be more information
clear and verified tomorrow tomorrow
there will be Ukrainian and
international journalists in izum we
want the world to know what is really
happening and what the Russian
occupation has led to bucha mariapol now
unfortunately isium Russia leaves death
everywhere
and must be held accountable for it the
world must bring Russia to real
responsibility for this war we will do
everything for this let's bring in Al
jazeer as Gabriel Elizondo in key for
escape not the first time that mass
graves are reported to have been found
after the retreat of Russian forces what
more are you hearing about this one in
Israel
well officials there in ISM are now
going through this Mass grave area a
forensic experts are there on scene
right now they say that they are going
to go through and exhume every single
site and examine every single remains
that they can find to try to figure out
names ages identities to get to the
bottom of this uh the officials there
are already signaling that they believe
these are all civilians and they also
are signaling at least early on in this
investigation that there are potentially
women and children among the dead this
was a site in ISM in a forested area
what they found were wooden crosses with
no names on them unmarked Graves only
numbers on all of the crosses this comes
as a Ukrainian reintegration uh forces
these are people that come in after the
military has swept through and reached
taken towns and Villages from the
Russians then another group of Ukrainian
officials comes through to try to
re-establish services to cities that
have been reclaimed by the ukrainians
and now these are the officials that
have discovered uh these Mass Graves for
potential Mass Graves now Moscow has not
commented so far on these claims by the
ukrainians but in the past Moscow has
said the Russians have said that they do
not Target civilians and they do not
participate in war crimes but the
ukrainians are already pointing to
situations such as bucha the town right
outside of Kiev where more than 458
bodies were found of ukrainians all
civilians after the Russians were pushed
out of that area early on in this war
they also point to more than 20 thousand
civilians and Military that were killed
in maripol in the South during a
weeks-long Russian Siege of that city a
city that the Russians still control
clearly now the focus is on these deaths
in zoom and we expect to have more
information on Friday because the
president of Ukraine as you just heard
voldemir zielinski said that they are
urgently trying to get information and
figure out how these people died and
release that information uh to
ukrainians and to the world and we will
come back to you of course throughout
the day Gabriel Elizondo in cave with
the latest on that story thank you for
the moment meanwhile ukrainians